by the way
um did you ever find out who [ __ ]
got in your house um
i don't i didn't find out who got in my
house i know what they look like
no i've seen i've seen the screenshots i
just didn't know if like anything ever
came with that did you ever getting your
[ __ ] back or
no because they were hitting houses like
in your neighborhood right yeah they was
they had a whole little thing going on
and then you know the police came
to the crib they thought i did it like
damn nearly like
it was the insurance policy they was
giving me the talk and i i almost got
hot with them in the crib
and then uh after that they had like
some
some uh i don't even know what the [ __ ]
you call them some police officers or
whoever
detective detective there we go i'm
[ __ ] police some detective that was
supposed to call me
and uh give me the rundown of what was
going on and updates and then every time
i
tried to hit them up there was never no
updates like that and i wasn't trying to
really keep up with the police like that
so i just kind of let it go
these fools i got jacked they jacked my
whip
i i was at the bank someone followed me
out of the bank
i'd stopped at the ups store while i was
in the ups store this was blew out my
back window
took 15 grand in cash out of my trunk
the cops had their car and they couldn't
like the license plate was like
fuzzy but they could have figured it out
they had video of the girl who followed
me out of the bank and got in that car
yeah and i never heard i'm like bro did
y'all even try to get my [ __ ] back
to be honest i tried way harder than
them for that first week
like i had gotten to a point where i'm
the one who got the footage because i
went
i went to the gas station that i stopped
at and i had to chip off the guy i said
look give me the footage
because they had to follow me here
because i went here before i went to the
other spot where i got robbed
and i had to give i gave the cops the
footage like i got the footage
that was right that's the same thing i
did i gave cops more footage and i went
to the neighbors and
it was like pointless it was one of
those things where they were supposed to
be able to go
through some other people's cameras in
the neighborhood and be able to spot
you know what i'm saying because i saw
the car but i couldn't see no plates and
then all right
the way that they dip it's it's a whole
run they got a whole route out the
neighborhood through the neighborhood
where they don't have
they knew what they were doing go
straight to the freeway i lost like
i lost like five chains i think my girl
lost like two chains did you have
insurance bracelet
um to be honest i did have
insurance but they wasn't covering that
they didn't cover it nah
they didn't cover anything oh that's
some [ __ ] i had paperwork and all
that [ __ ] and i i went through
you know i'm saying everything i needed
to go through but they wasn't covering
it
learning experience man yeah i learned
from it yeah well look kid ink
appreciate you coming through